i got a question for you guys what do
you guys think about the beard should i
keep the beard or should i have a goatee
i don't know let me know down in the
comment section anyway this episode was
amazing i loved this episode of what if
i still say the one with doctor strange
is the best and i feel like it's going
to be although i feel like if any of the
episodes are going to rival the one with
doctor strange it's going to be the one
with this tron vision ultron vistron
i want to call him viztron but at the
same time i feel like it's just
forced you know what i mean
you guys you know what i'm talking about
right it's just forced right so this
episode was cool first things first
party thor is the best thor i was one of
those people who was a fan of the fact
that they turned thor into more of a
comedic character in all honesty thor
being serious is okay but in the comics
i kind of find it to be more annoying
than anything else depending on the
circumstance but the idea of thor being
more of a comedic character not really
slapstick and silly he's still like got
it where it counts right where it's just
like okay
thor is still like a heavy hitter right
like you literally have the events of
like infinity war coming off the heels
of like thor three so like thor during
ragnarok as a comedic character and then
he has like storm breaker and he's just
like pissed you know during the events
of infinity war which is cool right
seeing him is still kind of like the
badass guy but also having those comedic
moments i love that right i think it
adds depth and i think it makes the
character more dynamic right so i was a
big fan of that seeing thor here you
know what this reminds me of it reminds
me of the comic where the beyonder right
that omnipotent guy who initiated the
original secret wars where like he comes
to earth and basically turns the world
into an 80s party right and it just goes
on that's actually the same story where
deadpool becomes venom for the first
time it was really really cool i'm sure
we covered over comics explained but
nonetheless i dug it right i dug this
episode i thought it was great but there
were a ton of easter eggs and little
cameos and things like that in this
episode so you saw your normal fair
share of the characters that we're
familiar with in the mcu right drax the
destroyer rocket raccoon different
characters like that we saw aisha from
guardians of the galaxy you guys might
remember her as the girl who basically
created adam warlock the funny thing
about her is she's actually kismet in
marvel comics which is kind of
interesting she's basically like the
female version of adam warlock her name
is technically her when she first shows
up but nonetheless it's cool to see her
in this uh it was interesting to see
that howard the duck was here and then
he married darcy
that's kind of wild it's cool but it's
kind of wild at the same time also let's
all just admit right the scene with like
everybody waking up in the hotel and
like jane foster is laying in her bed
her and thor banged right i'm sure
disney or somebody would be like i mean
look no they didn't there's like one
pillow on the bed right let me tell you
something man if you're doing it right
by the time you get done there'll be no
pillows on the bed so truth to tell
they were knocking boots right let's
just admit it right i'm sure they kind
of had to tone it down for the sake of
disney plus but i will say i think loki
as a frost giant is amazing i love the
way he looks as a frost giant i think he
looks better than he does when he's just
regular loki one thing that is a little
confusing to me i mean i understand the
idea of why he became a frost giant that
odin basically just like took him and
then was like nah never mind and then
took him back right so like gave him
back to king loffy my question is how
did loki and thor become friends right
was he told by odin at one point like i
almost adopted a brother for you but
then i changed my mind and gave him back
and then thor was like all right well
let's go let's go see what this is about
right and just kind of met up with him i
assume maybe it's over the course of
battles or something along those lines
but there seems to be like a
long-standing camaraderie there right
it's not like they became friends
yesterday and he's like hey man you seem
cool come hang out at the party we'll
get to know each other better right
we'll have a good time have some drinks
or whatever it seems that they've known
each other for a little while right so
i'd be kind of curious to see how that
unfolded i don't think it's worth a
whole episode but i'd be curious to see
like a tweet right or some some
interview in a news article somewhere
right where where the directors or the
writers like yeah man like ac bradley
just kind of explains the whole thing
it's like yeah man like it's
they've just been friends for a while
and here's how it happened speaking of
which ac bradley actually wanted this
episode to be one where jane foster lift
the hammer of thor but he couldn't do it
because they're gonna do it in thor four
so that's why this episode actually
ended up being a party thor episode
instead which you know cool i'm down
with it sirder tried to bang the statue
of liberty
he's throwing it out there
he tried to get it on with the statue of
liberty
ended up ripping her arm off in the
process which is kind of weird it was
funny because the whole thing is like
every teenager ever who's ever thrown a
party while their parents were gone and
then like when their parents come home
it's just like a mad dash to clean the
place up which kudos to thor for getting
it all sorted out and had he not been an
idiot and recalled his hammer to himself
and covered mardi gras beads he would
have been fine right so nonetheless you
know that's kind of a cool thing but i
will say this the ending of the episode
is actually the more most intriguing
part about all this right i'm in
agreement with most people out there the
episode's worth watching it for no other
reason than the ending of the episode
because this begged so many questions
number one the watcher seems surprised
by like ultron vision vis-tron whatever
showing up at the end of the episode
like he didn't see it coming it wasn't
supposed to happen and his arrival
really begs a bunch of questions right
because we know he's already a character
that's going to exist in the what if
series i think he's the final episode or
the second to last episode we only got
two left so it's one of the two episodes
coming out i believe it's the final one
but the idea of him having the infinity
stones is intriguing because the
question is does he exist in this
universe and if he does how is he
created because ultron was created in
response to the invasion of new york
during the original avengers movie you
guys remember that then in response to
the invasion of new york tony stark came
up with the idea that there needed to be
a kind of autonomous sort of police
force right world protection agencies
like the avengers albeit on an automated
scale on a much larger level it was
basically avengers world for marvel
comics and that that was all done
because of the events of the invasion of
new york the ultron singularity was
developed as a response to that and then
vision was developed as what was
supposed to be the perfect body for
ultron so one follows the other but if
the invasion of new york never happened
there'd be no reason to use the mind
stone as a means to develop any kind of
an artificial intelligence singularity
to kind of build this entire autonomous
avengers network on right so
there's no reason for ultron to exist
basically so why would he exist in this
universe the only real logic you can
draw from this is that he exists in
another universe but if he exists in a
different universe how do you get to
this universe he does have the infinity
stones but the infinity stones at least
in the comics only work in their native
universe you can't take infinity stones
from one universe into another universe
and use them they would just be useless
chunks of rock now we can largely assume
that may not necessarily be the case but
even during the loki tv show when you
had the desk of that one guy right that
weirdo that everybody loves that all
these infinity stones were sitting in
there and they were useless rocks they
couldn't be used right because they were
seemingly outside of their native
universe and they were basically in null
time right where there really wasn't
time or anything along those lines we
still assume it's kind of the quantum
realm but we're not really sure and so
because of that it really begs a lot of
questions here right it may be that his
use of the infinity stone right having
the infinity stones on his chest it's
really more ceremonial than anything
else kind of something to establish his
dominance right to remind him how like
imposing he is like he conquered his
whole universe by capturing the infinity
stones and now maybe he's trying to
expand out do i think that there's some
kind of connection between ultron slash
vision visitron whatever and like king
the conqueror like he's working for kang
i don't know i think it'd be cool if it
was i still believe that kang has agents
working in the multiverse for him with
like maybe promises of absolute power or
something like that like he'll give them
huge sections of the multiverse to rule
or something along those lines and then
kang being king would probably betray
them all at the end kill them all and
then rule the whole thing for himself
that's probably what kang would do he's
done it before he literally did it to an
alternate reality version of himself
named mortis right so i mean like this
happened before but nonetheless i don't
know if there's really any kind of a
connection there in truth we'll kind of
have to wait and see but what i do think
is cool here is that universes seem like
they're crossing over now again i'm
assuming that ultron vision vistron
whatever is not from this particular
party thor universe maybe he is right
maybe he is from this particular
universe is entirely possible but again
it still begs the question who made him
how was he created right i think he's
from an alternate reality which would
make sense given that each of the
what-if stories take place in their own
universe and we haven't seen that
version of ultron's what if store yet so
it makes sense that it's in a different
reality but the important thing here is
that the universes are basically
crossing over and that's something that
we pointed out when we were doing our
breakdown of the spider-man no way home
trailer as we were talking about how in
the loki tv show when the multiverse
came back that universes were crossing
over with each other and because they
were crossing over it was literally
leading to universes coinciding meshing
mixing characters that are crossing over
that are not supposed to cross over
right that kind of like juncture point
between universes could explain how it
is that vision managed to get his way
from his universe into this universe
right it would make perfect sense again
i don't know if that's actually the case
we're gonna have to wait till that
episode unfolds to find out but let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section again this was a fun
episode i will say that it's the most
fun of all the episodes that we saw thor
versus captain marvel cool right it's
the most interesting fight that nobody
asked for but it was interesting to see
so having said that guys let me know
what you think down in the comments
section thank you guys for watching and
i will catch you all later
peace